This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间专属于黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你有这种能力就必须去使用它，倾听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，以艰难的方式成长。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是“TWO.%”，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it's great to have you here back for another episode. Today,
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》（Girlfriends. Trust me, babe），在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。今天，
we're in for a freaking fascinating topic. I think we've all heard of inner child healing by this stage and the value in acknowledging and making peace with our childhood wounds. However, our childhood self is not the only past version of us that deserves love and attention. So today, we are going to expand on the principles and the theories behind healing our inner child to talk about healing our inner teen and what exactly that means and why it requires more of our focus. This is not spoken about enough, I think, because the idea of healing our inner child is a lot more. I would say, well, gentle and sweet and lovely. It's very easy to not blame our childhood selves for what they went through
我们将探讨一个极其迷人的话题。我想我们在这个阶段都听说过内在小孩疗愈，以及承认和抚平我们的童年创伤的价值。然而，我们童年时期的自我并不是唯一一个值得关爱和关注的过去版本的我们。所以今天，我们将扩展治愈内在小孩的原则和理论，来谈谈治愈内在青少年，这究竟意味着什么，以及为什么它需要我们更多的关注。我认为这个话题讨论得还不够，因为治愈内在小孩的想法要……怎么说呢，温和、甜美且可爱得多。我们很容易不去责怪童年时期的自己所经历的一切，
and how they're showing up in our adult behavior because of our innate vulnerability at that age. But our teenage selves are this whole different ballgame. I think I'm not the only one that looks back at my teen years with like an overtone of cringe, seeing the decision she made, the rage he felt for the world. but then also how alone she felt and misunderstood. It's this mixture of embarrassment and I guess also sadness. But what I've come to realize is that this version of me deserves just as much consideration and compassion
以及他们由于那个年纪天生的脆弱性而在我们的成年行为中表现出的种种。但我们的青春期自我完全是另一码事。我想我并不是唯一一个回顾自己的青春期时带有一种尴尬色彩的人，看到她做出的决定，他为世界感到的愤怒，但同时还有她感到的孤独和不被理解。这是一种尴尬与悲伤交织的混合体。但我开始意识到，这个版本的我也同样值得去体谅和同情，
as that younger version of myself and my current version of myself as well. The wounded teen looks a lot different to the wounded child, as we'll discuss. It's not just about needing love and care and security, but also about feelings of intense anger at times and rebellion and frustration. And this shows up in many ways like impulsive behaviors, emotional outbursts, self-sabotage, overspending, rejection sensitivity, all things that I think we could do without. So in today's episode, we are going to discuss it all. I will say that compared to healing our inner child. There is a lot less psychological research on this, but I think a lot of the foundational knowledge is still the same, as well as some of that emerging literature on things like
就像那个更年轻的我以及现在的我一样。受伤的青少年与受伤的儿童看起来有很大不同，正如我们将要讨论的那样。这不仅关乎对爱、关怀和安全感的需求，还关乎有时产生的强烈愤怒、叛逆和挫败感。这在许多方面表现出来，比如冲动行为、情绪爆发、自我破坏、过度消费、对拒绝敏感，这些都是我认为我们可以不需要的东西。所以在今天的节目中，我们将全面讨论这些。我必须说，与治愈内在小孩相比，这方面的心理学研究要少得多，但我认为许多基础知识仍然是相同的，还有一些关于压抑、早期青春期孤立、身份认同理论等事物的最新文献，以及一些关于诸如
suppression and early teenage isolation, identity theory, and also some really fascinating articles on events and experiences like our first time having sex, our first sexual experience, especially in our teenage years, things like that are a lot of. more impactful than we once thought. So we're going to break down the way that our wounded inner teen shows up and why the experiences during this period are highly influential for our adult selves. As much as we may try to avoid looking back at that time, we're also going to dive into some of the catalysts for our inner teen wounds, things like rejection, feeling excluded, parentification, and how we can identify with this lonely, angry, perhaps vengeful, impulsive version of us,
我们第一次性行为、第一次性体验等事件和经历的非常引人入胜的文章，特别是在我们的青春期，诸如此类的事情比我们曾经认为的要有影响力得多。因此，我们将剖析我们受伤的内在青少年是如何表现出来的，以及为什么这一时期的经历对我们的成年自我具有高度的影响力。尽管我们可能会极力避免回顾那段时期，但我们也将深入探讨我们内在青少年创伤的一些催化剂，比如被拒绝、感到被排挤、父职化（孩子承担父母角色），以及我们如何认同这个孤独、愤怒、或许心怀怨恨、冲动的自己，
but also how we can reconnect and how we can move forward. Some of the strategies will discuss include the adult chair method, one I haven't spoken about before, but which is so deeply influential. I cannot wait to discuss it. And also why listening to your old Taylor Swift or Blink 182 albums might actually be rather healthy for us. So I'm so fascinated by this topic. I'm really keen to get into it
以及我们如何重新建立联系并向前迈进。我们将讨论的一些策略包括“成人椅”方法，这是我以前没有谈论过的一种方法，但它却有着深远的影响。我等不及要讨论它了。还有为什么听你以前的泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）或Blink 182专辑实际上对我们相当有益。所以我对这个话题非常着迷。我真的很想深入探讨它，
because if this didn't make me realize how much I actually hated my teenage self, oh my goodness, there's a lot of work to be done there. And I also want to share how I've been approaching it and all the value that I've found in this level of deep retrospection. So I'm going to stop rambling. That's not why you're here. So without further ado, let's jump into how to heal your inner team.
因为如果这件事没有让我意识到我其实有多讨厌自己十几岁的时候，天哪，那里有大量的工作要做。我也想分享我是如何看待它的，以及我在这种深度的反思中发现的所有价值。所以我要停止闲聊了。你们来这里可不是为了听这个。因此，废话不多说，让我们直接进入如何治愈你的内在青少年。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是“T-W-O-P-P-Cent”，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过这一关的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，但只是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们却还在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、
pressure and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of Internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
压力和目标展开真实的对话，就在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难成长的教训》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她说法中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。索恩女士，你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news out of Maricopa County as, Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All right. So you've most likely heard of inner child healing before, especially if you are a long time listener of this show. I talk about it quite a lot because I think it's really valuable to understand how the experience. of our childhood self, impact our adult behavior, in particular our self-perception, and how we approach things like love and attachment and decision-making.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。好吧。所以你很可能以前听说过内在小孩疗愈，特别是如果你是这个节目的长期听众的话。我经常谈论这个，因为我认为理解童年自我的经历如何影响我们的成年行为，特别是我们的自我认知，以及我们如何对待爱、依恋和决策等事情，真的是非常有价值的。
In a child healing for a bit of a refresher, it essentially rests on the premise that within all of us is this injured, vulnerable being who needs caring for, who needs you to step up and parent them and show yourself the compassion. and the unconditional love, you maybe previously hadn't experienced. A core foundation of this practice is that past versions of ourselves still exist, even if our overall physical form has changed. Those experiences we had during our formative years, either in childhood or adolescence, they don't disappear.
为了复习一下，内在小孩疗愈本质上基于这样一个前提：我们每个人的内心都存在着这样一个受伤的、脆弱的个体，需要关怀，需要你挺身而出像父母一样照顾他们，并向自己展示你以前可能从未体验过的同情和无条件的长久的爱。这种实践的核心基础是，我们过去的自我版本依然存在，即使我们的整体身体形态已经改变了。我们在形成期（无论是在童年还是青春期）所经历的那些经历，并不会消失。
They stay with us as very emotionally present and salient memories, And so in some ways, we are still carrying every version of us that has come before, including all the baggage that they themselves were carrying. Now, whilst inner child work and talking about our inner child is really about reflecting on our emotional core, the vulnerable, innocent, often needy part of you, our inner team is a lot more messy, as they say. Maybe they're angry. Maybe they're isolated.
它们作为情感上非常鲜明和突出的记忆伴随着我们，所以在某种程度上，我们仍然背负着在我们之前出现的每一个版本的自己，包括他们自己所背负的所有包袱。现在，虽然内在小孩的工作和谈论我们的内在小孩主要是关于反思我们的情感核心——那个脆弱的、天真的、常常需要关怀的你，但我们的内在青少年要混乱得多，正如他们所说。也许他们很愤怒。也许他们很孤立。
Maybe they're misunderstood. this version of you, this past version, they were intellectually and emotionally developed enough to be able to rationalize what they were experiencing, but perhaps not to process it. And the nature of the experiences they went through that perhaps left these psychological scars are going to be very different. So approaching inner child healing and in a teen healing separately is really valuable. And the distinction is mainly the age at which you received certain emotional or social wounds. So your inner teenager is a representation of what you went through in your teen years, the emotional experiences that perhaps shaped you, and most importantly, how that is still impacting you today.
也许他们被误解了。这个版本的你，这个过去的版本，他们在智力和情感上已经发育到足以能够理性看待他们正在经历的事情，但可能还不足以去处理它。他们所经历的、或许留下了这些心理创伤的经历的性质将是非常不同的。因此，将内在小孩疗愈和内在青少年疗愈分开来看是很有价值的。而两者的区别主要在于你受到某些情感或社交创伤时的年龄。所以，你的内在青少年代表了你在十几岁时所经历的一切，那些或许塑造了你的情感体验，最重要的是，这在今天仍然如何影响着你。
And the age at which we had these experiences will impact how they manifest. So in developmental psychology, the distinction between children and adolescents, it's kind of more than just age. Yes, we kind of tend to see teenagers as those between the ages of 13 to 18 or 19. And that's our main way of categorizing this group of people. But during that time, we're also undergoing a really rapid level of development that distinguishes us from children. And it's not just physical because this is. the time when we really begin to figure out our identity and when we sit in the world. This includes things like our sexual identity, our relational identity, perhaps where we stand, you know, in
我们有这些经历时的年龄将影响它们如何表现出来。因此，在发展心理学中，儿童和青少年之间的区别不仅仅是年龄问题。是的，我们倾向于将青少年视为13岁到18或19岁之间的人。这是我们对这类人群分类的主要方式。但在那段时期，我们也正在经历一个极快速的发展水平，这使我们区别于儿童。这不仅仅是身体上的，因为这是我们真正开始弄清楚我们的身份以及我们在世界上的位置的时期。这包括诸如我们的性身份、关系身份、也许还有我们的立场，你知道，
relation to our parents and our peers. And then most importantly, I would say is our personal identity. It's kind of a combination of everything. Who are we actually? Who do we feel like we are? it's this stage of development that the psychoanalyst Eric Erickson called the conflict between identity and identity or role confusion. So during this stage, adolescents search for a sense of self through a really intense personal exploration of values, of goals, of belief systems, and they tend to also rebel against broader societal norms, particularly those represented in the fact. family unit as a way of going about this. So maybe from your personal experience, you had a bit of an emo phase during this time, got a few piercings your parents didn't approve of, listen to angsty music, you know, skipped school, drank alcohol, or you just kind of tried on different costumes or masks for who you wanted to be. Even though you may cringe at that now, it's actually
相对于我们的父母和同龄人而言。然后最重要的是，我认为是我们的个人身份。这可以说是各种因素的结合。我们究竟是谁？我们觉得自己是谁？正是这个发展阶段，精神分析学家埃里克·埃里克森（Eric Erickson）称之为同一性与同一性混乱（或角色混乱）之间的冲突。因此，在这个阶段，青少年通过对价值观、目标、信仰体系的强烈个人探索来寻找自我感，他们也往往会反叛更广泛的社会规范，特别是那些体现在家庭单元中的规范，以此作为实现这一目标的方式。所以也许从你的个人经历来看，这段时间你有点非主流（emo）阶段，打了一些父母不赞成的耳洞，听着充满焦虑的音乐，你知道的，逃学、喝酒，或者你只是尝试了不同服装或面具来扮演你想成为的人。尽管你现在可能会为此感到尴尬，但这其实
really valuable because what Erickson concludes is that if you don't give yourself that space to really figure that stuff out, if you don't make mistakes, if you don't successfully move through this stage or resolve that conflict between who we think we are, who society thinks we are, and our true self, this is when we begin to see some of those emotional and social wounds that are most characteristic of a wounded inner team. And at the same time, we're experiencing a lot of independence and a lot of, I would say, personal identity growth. We're also seeing a very big biological shift, you know, the beginnings of puberty. And this exacerbates a lot of the experiences that we ultimately need to move through.
非常有价值，因为埃里克森得出的结论是，如果你不给自己留出空间去真正弄清楚这些事情，如果你不犯错误，如果你没有成功度过这个阶段或解决我们认为的自己、社会认为的自己与真实的自己之间的冲突，这就是我们开始看到那些受伤的内在青少年最具特征的一些情感和社交创伤的时候。与此同时，当我们体验到大量的独立性和大量的个人身份成长时，我们也在经历着非常大的生物学转变，你知道，青春期的开始。这加剧了许多我们最终需要去经历的体验。
So beginning at puberty, the brain is literally being reshaped because we're going to start pruning some of those synapses and neural pathways that we know. longer need, but also hormonally, our bodies are being pumped with things like adrenal stress hormones, growth hormones and sex hormones like testosterone and estrogen. All of these greatly impact things like mood and impulse control, even our mental health. So there's been studies that have shown that higher rates of estrogen impact the availability of serotonin. So serotonin, as we know it more generally, it's one of the primary neurotransmitters responsible for happiness. So it kind of explains why women, in particular teenage girls who have such high levels of this hormone, have significantly
因此，从青春期开始，大脑实际上正在被重塑，因为我们将开始修剪一些我们不再需要的突触和神经通路，而且在荷尔蒙方面，我们的身体正被注入诸如肾上腺应激激素、生长激素和性激素（如睾酮和雌激素）等物质。所有这些都极大地影响着诸如情绪、冲动控制，甚至我们的心理健康。因此，有研究表明，较高水平的雌激素会影响血清素的可用性。因此，正如我们通常所了解的那样，血清素是负责快乐的主要神经递质之一。这就解释了为什么女性，特别是荷尔蒙水平如此之高的青春期女孩，由于当我们成为女人而不是女孩时发生的那些转变，会有显著
higher rates of things like anxiety and depression because of those shifts as we become, you know, women rather than girls. So what does this actually mean? It just sounds like a bunch of science. It means that what we're battling as teenagers is in some ways a lot more advanced than what we needed as children. Our inner child just wants love and security and attachment. And that probably feels very different to your inner teenager who has a lot of feelings of perhaps displacement and frustration, confusion and I think most importantly, insecurity. I think our teenage years is when we become clued into the world and perhaps very angry with what it has to offer. I remember feeling really misunderstood as a teenager.
更高比率的焦虑和抑郁。那这到底意味着什么呢？这听起来只是一堆科学术语。这意味着我们作为青少年所抗拒的东西，在某些方面比我们作为儿童时所需要对抗的东西要先进得多。我们的内在小孩只想要爱、安全感和依恋。这可能与你的内在青少年感觉非常不同，你的内在青少年有许多诸如被排挤和挫败感、困惑，而且我认为最重要的是不安全感的感觉。我认为我们的青春期正是我们开始了解这个世界，并且可能对它所提供的一切感到非常愤怒的时期。我记得自己十几岁时感到非常不被理解。
I would sit in my room for hours. I would have these bites with my parents. And for many of us, our transition into adolescence is marked by these very heightened emotions and a changing landscape around what society expects of us. The three main, I would say, social, cultural experiences are trying to find independent. and perhaps grow up a bit too fast, feeling misunderstood and maybe trying to be someone when not for other people's benefit. And then finally, the experience of shame. The last one in particular, I think, really distinguishes our childhood selves from our teenage selves.
我会把自己关在房间里好几个小时。我会和父母吵架。对我们许多人来说，我们向青春期的过渡标志着这些高度亢奋的情绪，以及围绕社会对我们的期望的不断变化的环境。我想说，三大社会、文化体验是试图寻找独立，并且可能成长得有点太快了，感到被误解，以及可能为了迎合他人而试图成为一个不是自己的人。最后，是羞耻的体验。特别是最后一点，我认为真正将我们的童年自我与青春期自我区分开来。
We start feeling shame as we enter our teenage years about our behavior and worrying about other people's perceptions of us. If you kind of think back to your childhood self, you really didn't have those concerns. You know, we were pretty happy to play and run around if you've ever spoken to like a seven or eight, even nine-year-old child. They say like the wildest shit. Like, they have no impulse control. And we would wear whatever we wanted. And I think it's important to notice, when did that stop? When was the first time you realized that maybe you'd, you'd, didn't fit in, or you became conscious of the expectations and opinions of others. And is that still impacting you now? In what ways is that teenage version of you still seeking out approval
当我们进入青春期时，我们开始对自己的行为感到羞耻，并担心其他人对我们的看法。如果你回想一下你的童年自我，你真的没有这些担忧。你知道，如果你和七八岁甚至九岁的孩子交谈过，我们当时其实挺乐意玩耍和到处奔跑的。他们会说出最疯狂的话。比如，他们完全没有冲动控制。我们会穿任何我们想穿的衣服。我认为重要的是要注意，这种状态是什么时候停止的？你第一次意识到自己可能不合群，或者开始意识到他人的期望和意见是什么时候？这在现在仍然在影响着你吗？青少年时期的那个版本的你，是否仍在通过某种方式在你的成年行为、你当前的生活中寻求他人的认可
from others in your adult behavior, in your current adult life? And then we also want to be, you know, perceived as older than we are. We're in such a rush to grow up, to push the limits. And yet, we actually don't really have the cognitive or emotional skills to process some of the things that we go through, particularly how they impact things like future attachment style and self-concept, because we are still very much children. That's how the legal system sees us, our voting system, our healthcare system, and yet we're having these very adult experiences in this weird limbo between childhood and adulthood. one of these experiences in particular is around sex.
然后我们也希望被视为比实际年龄更大。我们如此急于长大，突破界限。然而，我们实际上并不具备处理我们所经历的一些事情所需的认知或情感技能，特别是这些事情如何影响未来的依恋风格和自我概念等，因为我们实际上仍然非常像儿童。法律系统、投票系统、医疗系统都是这么看待我们的，然而我们却在这个童年与成年之间的怪异过渡期里经历着非常成年的体验。其中一个特别的体验就是关于性。
So the average age, most of us lose our virginity, is kind of smack bang in the middle of the teenage years, according to a lot of the research. So around 16 to 17. Now, I will say this is self-reported. So there may be some level of social desirability that people want to be seen as sexually active younger. But that kind of actually helps my point,
因此，根据大量研究，我们大多数人失去童贞的平均年龄正好在青春期的正中间。大约在16到17岁。现在，我要说的是这是自我报告的。因此可能存在某种程度的社会赞许性效应，人们希望被视为在更年轻的时候就有性活跃表现。但这实际上有助于支持我的观点，
that we really do want to grow up faster. And, you know, it's not everyone's experience. But for those of us who did have our first sexual experience during our teenage years, that may actually have a lot of long-term impacts that we don't really come to terms with until much later in life. And they've just, you know, conducted studies into this quite a few recently, actually, suggesting that the age of a person's first sexual experience can determine your romantic outcomes later in life. One study in particular published in the journal of sex and marital therapy, it kind of concluded that this is particularly profound for women and their later sexual desire
即我们确实渴望更快地长大。而且，你知道，这并不是每个人的经历。但对于我们这些在青春期确实有过第一次性体验的人来说，这实际上可能会产生许多长期的影响，直到生命的晚期我们才真正接受这一点。他们刚刚（实际上最近进行了相当多的研究）表明，一个人第一次性体验的年龄可以决定你日后的浪漫关系结果。发表在《性与婚姻疗法杂志》上的一项研究特别得出结论，这对女性及其后来的性欲有着尤为深远的影响，
because losing your virginity, you know, we don't really talk about it on the podcast, but it's such a powerful learning experience, and especially for our teenage years. And sometimes it can contain quite a bit of, you know, not just trauma, but a real sense of like we've suddenly grown up. We've suddenly, this is like this milestone that kind of really sits in our brains as teenagers. And we might feel like we're old enough to deal with things, you know, and take on adult responsibilities, like having sex,
因为失去童贞——我们在播客中其实并不经常谈论它——是一次如此强有力的学习体验，尤其是在我们的青春期。有时它可能包含相当多的，你知道的，不仅仅是创伤，还有一种突然长大了的真实感觉。突然之间，这就像是一个真正留在我们青少年大脑中的里程碑。我们可能会觉得自己已经够大了，可以处理事情（你知道的），并承担成年的责任，比如发生性行为，
but our brains aren't really fully developed until much later on. So, in essence, inner teen healing acknowledges those experiences that may have been quite painful, all the ways in which you're perhaps rejected or unheard or trying to fit in. and what we want to do is provide space to feel and verbalize and process all of that in a way that you know, your arrogance as a teenager, just kind of your naivety didn't let you do. What we might see is this power struggle around the fight for control, wanting to feel older than we are, and then also feeling very much alienated. And when we internalize these feelings, this contributes to a lot of uncomfortable,
但直到很久以后，我们的大脑才真正完全发育成熟。因此，从本质上讲，内在青少年疗愈承认了那些可能相当痛苦的经历，你被拒绝、被忽视或试图融入其中的所有方式，而我们想要做的是提供一个空间去感受、用言语表达和处理所有这一切，以一种你知道的，你作为青少年的傲慢、你的天真没有让你做到的方式。我们可能会看到围绕争夺控制权的权力斗争，渴望感觉比实际年龄更大，然后也感到非常疏离。当我们内化这些感觉时，这会导致许多不舒服的事情，
things and that's where the kind of premise lies. So what does it look like when your inner teen kind of takes control? So there are a few signs that you may have what we would call a wounded inner team and they'll differ from person to person but I want to list a few that are most commonly shared. So the first is being highly emotionally reactive or responding to situations in a matter that others see as immature, experiencing intense rejection, sensitivity, self-sabotaging behaviors like procrastination, overspending, even addictive behaviors, replicating early romantic experiences or partners, holding onto resentment, self-isolating, or even reverting to kind of like the silent treatment or withdrawal, feeling intense anger, you know, for no apparent reason, wanting to
而这就是前提所在。那么，当你的内在青少年接管控制权时，它会是什么样子的呢？因此，有几个迹象表明你可能拥有我们所谓的受伤的内在青少年，它们因人而异，但我想列出一些最常见的。首先是高度情绪反应化，或者以他人视为不成熟的方式对情况做出反应，经历强烈的拒绝敏感性，自我破坏行为（如拖延、过度消费，甚至成瘾行为），复制早期的浪漫经历或伴侣，心怀怨恨，自我孤立，甚至退回到冷暴力或退缩状态，无缘无故地感到强烈愤怒，想要
be violent or petty or scornful. And finally, regression, which is what we would call a maladaptive defense mechanism against stressful or overwhelming situations. So regression is not as common, but it's pretty profound. And it's a very interesting indicator of an inner teen or even a childhood wound. So it involves reverting to behaviors that are not age appropriate in order to kind of replicate a time when you felt safer and more secure. So for example, sucking your thumb when you're feeling really stressed, wanting to go and like hide away in your closet or go into the fetal position, even talking in like a baby voice or a stuffed, you know, using a stuffed animal from your childhood as kind of like a coping device, something to attach to. It's not as common as the others,
变得具有攻击性、小气或刻薄。最后是退行，我们称之为对压力或压倒性情况的适应不良防御机制。因此，退行虽然不太常见，但却相当深远。它是内在青少年甚至是童年创伤的一个非常有趣的指标。它涉及恢复到不适合年龄的行为，以便复制一个你感到更安全、更有保障的时期。例如，感到非常压力时吸吮大拇指，想要躲进衣柜里或蜷缩成胎儿姿势，甚至用娃娃音说话，或者用你童年时的毛绒玩具作为一种应对机制、一种依附的东西。这不如其他情况常见，
but, you know, things like temper tantrums could even fall under this category as well. It's just these things that we did to self-souve as younger versions of us that are no longer appropriate and yet we still rely on. So these behaviours are going to impact us all very differently, and there are certainly more than just this list. But opinions and kind of psychoanalytic psychology in particular really suggest that, that these emotional habits and behaviors are really indicative that at some stage, in your adolescence, you experience something that altered your ability to relate to yourself and relate to
但是，你知道，发脾气甚至也可以归入这一类。这些只是我们作为更年轻的自己用来自我安慰的事情，虽然不再合适，但我们仍然依赖它们。因此，这些行为对我们每个人的影响截然不同，而且肯定不止这份清单上的这些。但是，观点和心理分析心理学特别是表明，这些情感习惯和行为确实表明，在你的青春期某个阶段，你经历了一些改变你与自己及与
others in a sustainable and productive way. Once you kind of, I think it's one of those things when you start on this journey, you can't really come back. Like you may find that a lot of the behaviors or habits you've learned over time can be traced back to your teenage self. and a lot of the emotional conflicts that you encountered. For example, if you're a highly sensitive person and highly sensitive to any indicators of rejection, perhaps from a partner or a friend, and you respond by pulling away,
他人建立可持续和富有成效的关系的能力的事情。一旦你开始了这段旅程，我认为这是那种一旦开始就无法回头的旅程。你会发现，随着时间推移你所学到的许多行为或习惯都可以追溯到你的青少年时期，以及你所遇到的许多情感冲突。例如，如果你是一个高度敏感的人，对来自伴侣或朋友的任何拒绝迹象都高度敏感，并且你通过退缩来做出反应，
by acting cruelly, by feeling incredibly anxious, that may be indicative that at some stage as a teenager, you felt really excluded and you felt really unliked. And so you now feel like you have to work for people's, attention and you feel uncomfortable when they take away that feeling. You feel uncomfortable in a way that you want to have control over the situation because you didn't have control over feeling liked or feeling like your authentic self when you were younger. Another one that I find really interesting is when you continually replicate early romantic experiences, that might be indicative that you haven't really
通过表现得残酷，通过感到极其焦虑，这可能表明你在青春期的某个阶段真的感到被排挤和不受欢迎。因此，你现在觉得你必须为人们的关注而努力，当他们夺走这种感觉时你会感到不舒服。你会感到不舒服，以至于你想要对这种情况拥有控制权，因为当你年轻的时候，你无法控制自己是否被人喜欢，或者是否能做真实的自己。另一个我发现非常有趣的情况是，当你不断复制早期的浪漫经历时，这可能表明你还没有真正
processed how they were maybe quite negative and gave you the wrong impression of how love should be, but because you haven't come to terms with that, you're stuck in this really repetitive pattern. So I want to talk about what events or triggers or experiences create these reactions, specifically how did your inner teen come to be wounded? The biggest one, kind of in my personal opinion, I just find this one perhaps most relatable, is a time when you felt really rejected or ostracized, especially if you've been bullied or perhaps excluded by certain groups or supposed friends when you were a teenager. This is such a painful experience and it can leave very long-lasting psychological scars.
处理好它们可能是如何相当消极的，并给你留下了爱应该是什么样的错误印象，但因为你还没有接受这一点，所以你陷入了这种非常重复的模式中。所以我想谈谈是什么事件、触发因素或经历产生了这些反应，具体来说，你的内在青少年是如何受伤的？在我个人看来，最大的一个——我只是觉得这个可能最具有共鸣——是你感到被拒绝或排斥的时候，特别是如果你在十几岁时曾被霸凌或被某些群体或所谓的朋辈所排斥。这是一段非常痛苦的经历，它会留下非常持久的心理创伤，
particularly around our innate sense of self-worth and feeling worthy of friendship. Each of us has an innate need to belong and to be accepted by the social groups we are surrounded by. Belonging is actually our third most important need according to Maslow's hierarchy of need. It's just above things like literal food and shelter, but below things like a sense of esteem or identity. identity or self-actualization. So we need to belong before we can come to terms with our highest self. So if you perhaps didn't feel like you really had a place where you felt accepted as a teenager, you may have been unable to kind of undergo some of that discovery that other people did.
特别是在我们对自身价值的内在感受以及觉得自己配得上友谊方面。根据马斯洛的需求层次理论，我们每个人都有归属于周围社交群体的内在需求，并被其接受。归属感实际上是我们第三重要的需求。它仅次于诸如字面上的食物和住所之类的东西，但低于诸如尊严感、身份认同或自我实现之类的东西。因此，在能够面对最高版本的自我之前，我们需要有归属感。所以，如果你十几岁时觉得自己没有一个真正被接受的地方，你可能就无法像其他人那样经历某种程度的探索。
What that means is that in adulthood, when we feel like we are being excluded like we spoke about before, that hurt, lonely, teenage version of us who maybe spent time really longing for the future, who really just wanted to belong, who wanted a friend. That version of us is activated and it begins to take control, perhaps isolating you even further. We see this in so many ways because we are worried that we will be hurt again, that people won't accept us. We can react by becoming quite codependent with just one person. Feeling intense anger at even the slightest sense of rejection. All of these being indicators of some deeper emotional origin or dysregulation. One way in particular I've actually seen this exhibited in my own behavior is the need to almost
这意味着在成年后，当我们觉得像我们之前谈到的那样被排斥时，那个受伤的、孤独的、曾经花时间渴望未来的、真正只想有归属感、想要一个朋友的青春期版本的我们就会被激活，并开始掌控局面，甚至可能让你进一步被孤立。我们在很多方面都看到了这一点，因为我们担心自己会再次受到伤害，担心人们不会接受我们。我们可以通过与单一个人变得高度共生来做出反应。甚至对哪怕是最轻微的拒绝感也表现出强烈的愤怒。所有这些都是更深层的情感根源或失调的指标。我实际上在自己的行为中看到这种情况表现出来的一种方式，就是几乎想要囤积或收集朋友的冲动，有时甚至在不同的人或群体面前表现出不同的个性和身份，因为我希望他们喜欢我，
hoard or like collect friends and sometimes even take on different personalities or identities with different people or groups because I want them to like me. want them to accept me. It's definitely something I've had to work on over the past five years. You know, filling up our social calendars or our circles with so many people that we can't even maintain all the relationships at once is really in some ways our subconscious brain saying, you know, hey, if we do this, we'll never have to feel alone again. We'll never have to feel rejected because there will always be someone there. I think the second thing that we can see really cause in a teen wounds has to do with parentification. So I talked about this in our hyper-independence
希望他们接受我。这绝对是我过去五年一直在努力克服的事情。你知道，用这么多人填满我们的社交日程或社交圈，以至于我们甚至无法同时维持所有的关系，在某种程度上确实是我们的潜意识大脑在说：“嘿，如果我们这样做，我们就再也不用感到孤独了。我们再也不用感到被拒绝了，因为总会有人在那里。”我认为第二件我们可以看到真正导致内在青少年创伤的事情与父母角色倒置（父职化）有关。我在超独立这一集里谈到了这一点，我认为这是发展心理学中涌现出的最迷人的概念之一。当我们在童年或青春期与父母或照顾者发生角色互换时，就会发生父职化。在这种情况下，我们不得不为他们提供情感支持，而不是反过来，我们充当了他们的知己或调解人。这种角色逆转扰乱了成熟的自然过程，因为我们作为青少年被迫承担了
episode and I think it's one of the most fascinating concepts to kind of come out of developmental psychology. Parenthification occurs when we experience a role reversal with our parents or caregivers as children or teenagers. In this way, we kind of had to provide them with the emotional support, not the other way around, and we acted as they're confident or their mediator. This role reversal disrupts the natural process of maturing because we've been forced to take on responsibilities
远远超出了我们年龄所需的责任。我们也被剥夺了那种有点无助的机会，不能让别人帮助我们，不能为自己犯错留出空间。这种过度成熟的后果可能会在日后生活中显现出来，比如我们表现出叛逆或做一些冲动、冒险的事情，因为我们在青春期没有得到那种机会。我们也可能高度情绪化，特别是在我们感到受限制或有责任感时，因为我们的内在青少年再次在这个情境中占据了主导地位。
as adolescents well beyond what our years should require. And we were also denied that kind of chance to be a little bit helpless, to have someone help us and to provide room for us to make mistakes. The consequences of this advanced maturity may show up later in life, you know, by us acting out or doing impulsive, risky things because we didn't get that opportunity as teenagers. We may also be highly emotionally reactive, particularly when we feel a sense of restriction or responsibility, because our inner team is once again, in this situation in control.
那些未愈合的创伤正根据过去的经历告诉我们要以某种特定方式行事。同样的情况也适用于诸如控制了我们身份认同的严厉父母之类的事情，他们不允许我们度过那个角色混淆阶段，不允许我们进行探索或犯错。这让我们对权威产生了一种几乎是仇恨的感觉。你可能会在日后的生活中与那些处于更高职位的人（比如你的老板）相处时遇到困难，他们告诉你该做什么，而你却表现出挑衅，因为这触发了你那个感到被误解且不被允许犯错的青少年时期的自己。
Those unheeled wounds are telling us to act in a certain way based on past experiences. And the same kind of goes for things like strict parents that may have contained our identity, not kind of allowing us to pass through that role confusion stage or to be exploratory or to make mistakes. This gives us a sense of almost hatred for authority. And you may struggle later in life with people in higher, positions like your boss telling you what to do, acting in defiance because it's triggering that teenage version of you who felt misunderstood and wasn't allowed to make mistakes.
那些未愈合的创伤正根据过去的经历暗示我们以某种特定的方式行事。严格的父母可能也有限制我们身份认同的类似效果，他们不允许我们经历角色混乱的阶段，不允许我们去探索或犯错。这让我们对权威产生了一种近乎憎恨的情绪。你可能会在以后的生活中，在面对像老板这样处于高位并对你指手画脚的人时感到难以应付，你会表现出叛逆，因为这触发了那个曾觉得自己被误解且不被允许犯错的青少年的你。
Narcissistic parents and also the kind of environment they created fall under the same banner. I think it's a major contributor feeling like you were forced to maintain a certain image for their benefit that might come with a lot of future rebellion or anger and then finally major life changes in adolescence. And I'm talking about things like the death of a parent or a close family member, maybe divorce, maybe you moved around a lot. What this all links to is, A, that pressure to grow up too fast, not giving our teenage self the time to properly come into their own and experience the important events they needed to at the proper time. And be a sense of alienation or disconnection and with that a lot of unresolved emotions like frustration and rage and
自恋型父母以及他们所创造的环境，其实都属于同一类情况。我认为这是导致以下感觉的主要原因：你觉得为了他们的利益，自己被迫维持某种特定的形象，这可能会伴随着未来大量的叛逆或愤怒，最后在青春期引发重大的人生改变。我指的是诸如父母或亲密家庭成员的离世、可能的离婚，或者频繁搬家。这一切所关联的是：第一，那种被催熟的压力，没有给我们十几岁的自己足够的时间去真正成熟，并在适当的时候经历他们所必需的重要事件；第二，一种疏离感或断联感，随之而来的是许多未解的情绪，比如沮丧、狂怒以及
resentment the kind of simplified premise of why we need to focus on our inner teen and not just our inner child is this the wounds we carry from our adolescents are going to be a lot more nuanced than the unmet needs we faced as children they will overlap but how they show up later in life is profoundly different in that our teenage wounds are a lot more active. So for example, our inner child wants peace and they want love and security. And our inner teens want that as well, but they also want expression and identity and rage, but ultimately acceptance. So what I want to discuss next is how to actually heal this wound and come to regard it as a really important element of who we are.
怨恨。我们需要关注内心深处的青少年（而非仅仅是内心的小孩），其简化的前提是这样的：我们从青春期承载的创伤，会比我们在童年时期面对的未满足需求要微妙得多；它们会有所重合，但它们在晚年生活中的表现形式却截然不同，因为我们的青春期创伤要活跃得多。所以，举个例子，我们内心的小孩渴望平静，渴望爱与安全感。而我们的内心青少年也同样渴望这些，但他们还渴望表达、身份认同和愤怒，但归根结底，是渴望接纳。所以接下来我想讨论的是，如何真正疗愈这个创伤，并开始把它视为我们生命中非常重要的一个元素。
And, you know, as they say, we sometimes do really need to share. shake hands with who we are and to reach that next stage of self-actualization, part of that process is managing those inner feelings and those inner wounds. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that
而且，正如他们所说，有时我们确实需要与真实的自我握手言和，为了达到自我实现的下一个阶段，这个过程的一部分就是管理那些内心深处的感受和创伤。因此，在短暂的广告休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾相信
seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。就在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it
或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》
podcast. I'm Sam J. and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J），我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·hill（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在节目里聊可卡因，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在计分看比分。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想成为一个好人而去做。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我凯尔·盖恩斯陪伴，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App，
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I think about my teenage self, I really remember the,
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。
this girl who was really struggling with a sense of place and identity. I haven't really spoken much about my high school experience because it feels like a lifetime ago, but I went to this like really progressive school where everyone was studying, you know, music or art and, you know, it was in Brunswick in Melbourne. So everyone was just like really cool. They were really cool. And I did not, I did not feel cool. I was academic. I was really studious. I played the trombone and I never really felt like anyone understood me. Felt very alone and that created a lot of negative feelings, probably a bit of depression, but also anger at the world for kind of treating me unfairly. On the other side of this was this need to be a good girl. I wasn't going to be a bad girl
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式起诉欺诈罪。在正义降临亚利桑那州之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。当我回想起我十几岁的自己，我真的记得
because I didn't fit in with the kind of kids that were rebelling and I also wanted everyone to like me. I needed the validation of others like it was water. And when I didn't receive it, when I didn't get the grades that I wanted or I felt excluded, I would project that kind of onto my parents or onto like the system. So I think what I've reflected on a lot is that in many ways, I really didn't allow myself a teenage experience because I was A, always worried about what others thought of me. And B, I was really deeply committed to being good.
那个一直在努力寻找归属感和自我认同的女孩。我其实没有怎么谈论过我的高中经历，因为那感觉就像是好几辈子前的事了，但我去了一所非常进步的学校，每个人都在学习音乐或艺术，而且它位于墨尔本的布伦斯维克。所以每个人都真的很酷。他们真的很酷。而我，我一点也不觉得自己酷。我是个学术型的人，我非常刻苦学习，我吹长号，而且我从来不觉得有人能真正理解我。我感到非常孤独，这产生了许多负面情绪，可能还有一点抑郁，但同时也有对这个世界待我不公的愤怒。这一切的另一面，是渴望成为一个好女孩的需要。我不会成为一个坏女孩，
And you know what happened after high school? I completely regressed and I became incredibly rebellious because I hadn't allowed myself to act out to try different versions of myself. So when I went to uni, I decided I wanted to speed up that progress. I wanted to grow up quickly like we talked about. And I kind of partied really hard. I got tattoos. I spent all my money going to Europe. I dyed my hair.
因为我无法融入那些叛逆的孩子，而且我也希望每个人都喜欢我。我对他人认可的需求就像需要水一样。而当我没有得到认可，当我没有取得想要的成绩或者觉得自己被排挤时，我会把那种情绪投射到我的父母身上，或者投射到体制上。所以我想我反思了很多的一点是，在很多方面，我真的没有允许自己拥有一个青春期体验，因为第一，我总是担心别人怎么看我；第二，我深深地执着于当一个好孩子。
I smoked cigarettes behind my college blocked. I missed classes because my inner teen, now I can see. really missed out. And she was trying to make up for lost time. Slowly, as I got older, I obviously have begun to settle down. And I came to terms with what was really at the root of this behavior that seemed so very contradictory to the version of myself, you know, 12, even six months before. And the first step to coming to terms with that was noticing where I hurt. What was I afraid of that was causing this behavior? Because, not all of it was bad, as we'll talk about in a second, you know, contained rebellion is actually
你知道高中毕业后发生了什么吗？我彻底退化了，变得极其叛逆，因为我之前没有允许自己去放纵、去尝试不同版本的自我。所以当我上大学时，我决定加速那个进程。想像我们之前讨论过的那样，快快长大。我开始疯狂派对。我文了身。我花光所有的钱去欧洲旅游。我染了头发。
one really valuable way to get in touch with your inner teen. But really, you know, what was I fighting? What was at that core? And it was this very foundational insecurity. I wanted to belong. I wanted to be liked. I never felt like I was meant to be somewhere. And I never really gave myself permission to make mistakes. And so all of that pain and suppression had bubbled to the surface. I think if you want to heal your inner teen, you have to be able to identify when they have control or are reacting to this situation. I want to return to those indicators from before. So things like being highly emotionally reactive, angry outbursts, self-sabotaging, withdrawing, replicating early romantic experiences and regression. I also, I think part of that is under self-sabotaging behaviors is
我在大学宿舍后面抽香烟。我逃课，因为我内心的青少年——现在我能看出来了——真的错过了太多。她试图弥补失去的时间。慢慢地，随着年龄的增长，我显然开始安定下来。我开始正视这种行为背后的根源，这些行为与仅仅十二个月、甚至六个月前的那个我简直判若两人。正视它的第一步，就是去注意我在哪里受了伤。究竟是什么让我感到恐惧，从而导致了这种行为？因为，并非所有行为都是坏事，正如我们一会儿要谈到的那样，有节制的叛逆其实是
things like overspending and things like procrastination. So let's kind of look at overspending as an example. Money is something that we all struggle with, I would say. I think our relationship to spending is highly influenced by how money was approached in our adolescence and within our family system. It's a very unique in a teen experience to worry about money because I think we only really become conscious of its value in those later years. So if your family always struggle with money when you kind of begin to make your own income, you might find that it's really hard to not spend without thinking, kind of as a way to fulfill material needs that you never felt you got to experience at a younger age.
与内心青少年建立联系的一种非常有价值的方式。但说到底，我在对抗什么？那个核心究竟是什么？正是这种非常基础的不安全感。我渴望归属感。我渴望被人喜欢。我从来不觉得自己属于任何地方。我也从来没有真正允许自己犯错。因此，所有的痛苦和压抑都涌上了水面。我认为，如果你想疗愈内心的青少年，你必须能够识别他们在什么时候掌控了局面，或者是在对某种情况做出反应。我想回到之前提到的那些指标。比如高度的情绪反应、愤怒爆发、自我毁灭、退缩、复制早期的恋爱经历以及行为倒退。我还认为，自我毁灭行为的一部分是
And adulthood is expensive. So, you know, spending money on your rent or to fix your car or for healthcare, that is not what I would call overspending. It's the money we put towards our wants rather than our needs. So if you find that you have a tendency to overspend when you're stressed or when you're lonely or you feel out of control, maybe that's your inner team. In that moment, you have to recognize this version of yourself. It's kind of asking you to recognize them, is asking you to look at them face on and really
诸如过度消费和拖延之类的事情。那么，让我们把过度消费当作一个例子。金钱是我们所有人都在苦苦挣扎的事情，我想可以这么说。我认为我们与消费的关系，深受我们在青春期以及家庭系统中对待金钱方式的影响。为金钱操心是一种非常独特的内心青少年体验，因为我认为我们只有在后来的岁月中才会真正意识到它的价值。所以，如果你的家庭总是为钱发愁，当你开始自己赚钱时，你可能会发现很难做到花钱不假思索，这其实是一种去满足物质需求的方式——那些你在年幼时觉得从未体验过的需求。
trying to assert their independence and authority kind of at the detriment of your adult sense of responsibility. Now, the crucial tip here is to not fully suppress this behavior. We know from psychological research that suppressing certain urges is about as effective. as complete avoidance or abstinence. It may feel effective in the short term, but over time, you cannot rely on wheelpower alone. That behaviour of feeling or instinct is going to feel more taboo and therefore a lot more attractive and I guess you'll relapse, you'll feel shame, you'll spend more and you're back in the toxic cycle with your kind of wounded team at the wheel. So you need to
成年生活是很昂贵的。所以，把钱花在房租上、修车上或医疗保健上，这不是我所说的过度消费。我们花在“想要”而不是“需要”上的钱才是。所以，如果你发现自己在压力大、孤独或感到失控时倾向于过度消费，那可能就是你内心的青少年在作祟。在那一刻，你必须认出这个版本的自己。他们要求你认出他们，要求你直面他们，并且在很大程度上
find an outlet and give yourself permission to actually connect with that need, acknowledge where it's coming from and why, and then treat it like a welcome visitor. For example, budgeting for free spend money that you can spend on whatever you want within limits. Anger is another example. Often when our wounded teen is kind of speaking up, it's through things like rage or outbursts or tantrums and it's possibly caused by us feeling the need to suppress this feeling for quite a while and if we look at the origins it may have been that as a child you weren't really given permission to feel emotions intensely so as an adult you don't have the same level of
试图维护他们的独立性和权威，而这往往是以牺牲你成年的责任感为代价的。这里至关重要的建议是，不要完全压抑这种行为。我们从心理学研究中得知，压抑某些冲动，其效果大致相当于完全逃避或戒绝。它在短期内可能感觉有效，但随着时间的推移，你无法单靠意志力。那种行为、感觉或本能会变得更加禁忌，因此也更具吸引力，我猜你会复发，会感到羞耻，会花更多的钱，然后又回到了那个由受伤的青少年掌舵的恶性循环中。所以你需要
self-control that others may have it feels nice to be angry it's highly satisfying but you need to channel that in a productive way to satisfy both your inner teens needs and your adult needs as well. So go to a rage room. I did one of those the other day. It was honestly so fun. You can go to a boxing class or better yet, go to a nice secluded spot out in nature and just scream or dance intensely in your room. Headphones on, Blink 182, some fearless by Taylor Swift, classic teenage angst albums, and let out all of that stuff. emotions like rage and anger, they are stored in the body. This study conducted in 2016, it was published in the Oxford Academic.
找到一个宣泄口，并允许自己真正与那种需求建立联系，承认它来自哪里以及为什么，然后像对待一个受欢迎的访客那样对待它。例如，为“自由支配资金”做预算，在限额内你可以把钱花在任何你想花的地方上。愤怒是另一个例子。通常当受伤的青少年发声时，是通过狂怒、爆发或发脾气等形式，这可能是因为我们觉得自己有必要将这种情绪压抑相当长的一段时间；如果我们追溯其根源，可能是因为你在小时候并没有真正被允许强烈地表达情感，所以作为一个成年人，你并没有具备其他人可能拥有的那种程度的
It found that anger can create muscle tension and automatic arousal in certain areas of the brain. So giving this feeling of physical expression will stop you from doing so inappropriately. And it feels so nice to give yourself permission to actually feel. rather than scolding your inner teen as, you know, was often done by your parents or by teachers, do express that in a productive way. And that's also really important because a lot of researchers have concluded that when we store anger and then we let it out through lashing out or drinking or other things like that, this just creates addictive behavior. So give in and let go in a way that is emotionally fulfilling.
自我控制力。生气感觉很好，极具满足感，但你需要以一种富有成效的方式来引导它，以同时满足你内心青少年的需求和你的成年人需求。所以去发泄屋吧。我前几天刚去过一个。老实说，真的太好玩了。你可以去上拳击课，或者更好的是，去大自然中一个漂亮的幽静地方大喊大叫，或者在房间里剧烈地跳舞。戴上耳机，听着Blink 182的歌，或者泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的《Fearless》，那些经典的青春期焦虑专辑，把所有的情绪都宣泄出来。像狂怒和愤怒这样的情绪，它们是被储存在身体里的。2016年进行的一项研究，发表在《牛津学术期刊》上，
and when you catch yourself governed by your wounded in a teen, it's important to not believe everything that they're telling you. You don't want to feed into those beliefs that you'll never be loved or accepted or happy. Positively reaffirm why all of that isn't true, speaking to them as if they are a separate person, as if they, you know, that version of you, that angry, depressed teenager is sitting in front of you right now. and then try to switch back to your adult self, focus on the life you've now created for yourself, knowing you'll be okay, and comfort them with that foresight. There's one final method here that I really want to discuss. So I discovered this technique through this podcast called The Adult Chair Podcast
发现愤怒会在大脑的某些区域产生肌肉紧张和自主觉醒。因此，给予这种感觉以身体上的表达，会阻止你不合时宜地发泄出来。允许自己真正去感受，而不是像父母或老师那样经常做的那样去斥责内心的青少年，这种感觉真的太美妙了。以富有成效的方式表达出来吧。这同样非常重要，因为许多研究人员得出结论，当我们把愤怒积攒在心里，然后通过大发雷霆、喝酒或其他类似的方式发泄出来时，这只会滋生上瘾行为。所以，去纵容它、释放它吧，以一种在情感上能带来满足感的方式。
by Michelle Chalfent. Now when I say this method has absolutely changed my life, I'm being dead serious. And in all of my courses and psychology studies, I'd really, I'd never heard of this before. So what this method asks you to do is to use three chairs to represent or symbolize your inner child, your inner teen and your current self, your adult self. And working with this model, we're going to understand how you feel on the inside and what needs to be healed, what might be damaged. So you sit with the three chairs real or imagined and you speak to each of these versions of yourself. What stories would your teenage self tell you? What was going on in that phase of life? And how did that feel? Literally monologue as if you were that version of yourself writing your autobiography.
当你发现自己被受伤的内心青少年所支配时，重要的是不要相信他们对你说的每一句话。你不想去助长那些认为自己永远不会被爱、被接纳或快乐的信念。要进行积极的心理自我肯定，去解释为什么所有这些都不是真的，跟他们对话时，就像他们是一个独立的人一样，就好像那个版本的你——那个愤怒、沮丧的青少年此刻正坐在你面前，
I don't know, this is kind of intimate and a bit vulnerable. But the first time I did this, I also had my old journals from when I was a teenager. If you've got your old journals, you should really read through them because it was so emotionally profound. I genuinely cried because it felt so real and so honest and raw and it made me contemplate things that I hadn't for so long and remember things that I could see in my current behavior and take that load for them, you know, tell them that everything is going to be okay, tell them about the things they never would have expected that it does get better, that you're pushing through and that you love them. Now, I know when I talk about these techniques, will find them quite strange. But I think what the very simple psychology would tell you is that
然后试着切换回你成年的自我，专注于你现在为自己创造的生活，确信自己会好起来的，并用这种长远的眼光去安慰他们。这里还有一个我非常想讨论的最后方法。我是通过一个名为《The Adult Chair Podcast》的播客节目发现了这个技巧，
it is your job to process how your memories and experiences have shaped you. And part of that is integrating them into the current version of yourself. Finding a place where these experiences sit in your current reality. This is kind of just one exercise that allows us to do that. and it kind of lets us answer that deep question at the very core of inner teen healing. What does this version of myself need? What are they missing right now that is causing them to react? And how can I give them that? It's also valuable to know, I think, much like in a child healing,
主播是米歇尔·查尔芬特（Michelle Chalfent）。当我说这个方法绝对改变了我的人生时，我是极其认真的。在我所有的课程和心理学学习中，我真的、从未听说过这个。所以这个方法要求你使用三把椅子来代表或象征你的内心儿童、内心青少年以及你当前的自我，也就是成年自我。通过这个模型，我们将了解你内心的感受以及什么需要被疗愈、什么可能受到了损害。你坐在那三把椅子上（无论是现实中还是想象中的），与你自我的每一个版本对话。你十几岁的自己会告诉你什么样的故事？那个生活阶段发生了什么？感觉如何？
healing your inner teen is a lifelong process, but one that gets easier. I think some final reminders would be this. With anything that happens in life, you need to choose. to be gentle with yourself. Self-punishment, unfortunately, never works. It's really just our ego punishing us or relieving a sense of guilt that we don't know how to process. Two, make friends with who you are. Your past self helped you get here. Whatever they went through. Whatever ways they were misbehaving or were cringe, it's all still valuable. It's all part of the journey. And part of that is three, getting to know yourself better. I think at the core of this podcast,
字面意思上，就像你在写自传一样，以那个版本的自己进行独白。我不知道，这听起来有点私密，也有点脆弱。但我第一次这样做的时候，我把我当青少年时的旧日记也拿出来了。如果你有旧日记，你真的应该翻看它们，因为这在情感上太深刻了。我真心流泪了，因为它感觉那么真实、那么诚实、那么赤裸，它让我开始思考那些我好久没去想的事情，想起了那些我能在自己当前行为中看到的画面，并为他们承担那个负担，你知道的，告诉他们一切都会好起来的，告诉他们那些他们永远意想不到的事情——生活确实会变好，你正在咬牙坚持，你爱他们。现在，我知道当我谈论这些技巧时，
is the idea that all of us could benefit from some additional introspection and self-awareness. And if part of that is acknowledging your teenage wounds, then I really think that's amazing. So I really hope that this episode has benefited you. We talk so much about inner child healing on this podcast. I think that our teenage selves get a little bit neglected at times, which is not helpful, as we have learned. So I'm hoping that this episode has really allowed you to contemplate how this version of you was showing up in your life.
有些人会觉得它们很奇怪。但我认为最简单的心理学原理会告诉你：
And yeah, just where you're at with that version of you, did you feel lonely? Did you feel neglected? Did you feel angry at the world? And have you really come to terms with what that meant and how that's still impacting you? So I'm so glad that you've made it this far. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to share it with a friend or give us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I'm going to plug my Patreon here if you like this episode for just $1 a month, $1, $1.
处理你的记忆和经历是如何塑造了你的，这是你的工作。而这其中一部分就是将它们融入当前版本的自我中。在你的现实生活中为这些经历找到一个安放之处。这只是允许我们做到这一点的其中一个练习，
You can help me make more of this show. It's really just me here doing it all, writing the episodes, doing the research. And I love it so much, but there is a lot of work that goes behind it. So I really appreciate the support. And if you have an episode suggestion, follow us at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. I love to hear what's going on in your lives. And you can see video content over there and just be part of the community. So we will be back next week with another episode. Thanks.
它让我们能够回答内心青少年疗愈核心深处那个深刻的问题：这个版本的自己需要什么？他们现在缺少什么导致了他们的反应？我该如何给予他们这些？同样值得了解的是，我认为，就像内心儿童疗愈一样，
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
疗愈内心的青少年是一个终生的过程，但会变得越来越容易。我想最后的提醒是这些。无论生活中发生什么，你需要选择对自我温柔以待。不幸的是，自我惩罚永远不管用。它实际上只是我们的 ego（自我）在惩罚我们，或者在宣泄一种我们不知道如何处理的内疚感。第二，与真实的自我交朋友。你过去的自己帮助你走到了今天。无论他们经历过什么，无论他们有哪些不端行为或显得尴尬，这一切仍然都是有价值的，都是旅程的一部分。而这其中一部分就是第三点，更好地了解自己。我认为这个播客的核心，
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
就是这样一个理念：我们所有人都能从一些额外的内省和自我觉察中受益。如果这其中的一部分是承认你的青春期创伤，那么我真的觉得这太棒了。所以我真心希望这一集对你有所帮助。我们在本播客中经常谈论内心儿童的疗愈。我认为我们十几岁的自我有时被忽视了，正如我们所了解的那样，这可不是什么好事。所以我希望这一集真的能让你去思考，这个版本的你是如何在你的生活中展现自己的。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
是的，就你与那个版本的自己的关系而言，你是否曾感到孤独？你是否曾感到被忽视？你是否曾对这个世界感到愤怒？你是否真的已经正视了这意味着什么，以及它如何仍在对你产生影响？我很高兴你能听到这里。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时与朋友分享，或者在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方给我们一个五星好评。如果喜欢这一集，我想在这里宣传一下我的Patreon，每月只需1美元，1美元，1美元，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你就可以帮我制作更多这样的节目。这里真的只有我一个人在包办一切，写剧本、做研究。我非常热爱这一切，但背后有很多工作要做。所以我真的很感激你们的支持。如果你有节目建议，请在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。我喜欢听你们生活中发生的事情。你可以在那里看到视频内容，并成为这个社区的一部分。我们下周将带着另一集回归。谢谢。